alwyn qu'est ce que cherche à dans les
années 90 commerçants publicitaire
amoureux de la culture anglo saxonne
tente d'instaurer la fête d'halloween en
france halloween est une fête d'origine
celte n'ont toujours pas alors j'en ai
entendu parler nous convient pas à
l'époque dans certains quartiers souvent
à l'initiative de familles anglaises ou
américaines
des soirées halloween sont organisées
mais même pour les premiers intéressés
les us et coutumes restent floues ou
allégeance au port même à saint pierre
et miquelon pourtant les plus proches du
canada les enfants ne sont pas ultra à
l'aise avec le folklore de la fête des
morts demain quand tu vas aller frapper
aux portes des maisons qu'est ce que tu
vas dire en rentrant nature crise et
c'est quoi ça bâcher le choc en poids
quand on fera part il ya beaucoup de
gens qui disent tout si aujourd'hui
quelques enfants réclament encore des
bonbons le 31 octobre au soir
halloween est un échec commercial pour
les adultes
en même temps certains français partait
de très très loin c'est une chanson
genton nous sommes à leur maillot
halloween c'est une chance
les
[Musique]